one time i walked in on him naked
and his thing is so small
how small is it if it were an ipod it
would be a shuffle
[Applause]
um michael the custodian from raskin
design is on the line he said they found
your keys in the koi pond okay thank you
did you say koi pond
yeah michael people are asking questions
uh okay put them on speaker hey guys
what's going on hey michael did you fall
into a koi pond uh i can't really hear
you i i think we sort of have a bad
connection jim did michael fall into a
koi pond um
it's like michael said it was um some
something else it was okay this is what
it was it was these bunch of idiots that
had put a fish tank in the ground with
no cover and no railing so you fell in
no maybe i was trying to save a child
that had fallen in so a child had fallen
in not yet that is hilarious no it don't
i'm not gonna bump i'm not gonna bump
and it was not hilarious it was very
very terrifying
truthfully it wasn't the way he fell in
it was how long it took him to get out
hey aaron do we have any of those clips
that hold paper together staples
uh david wallace called oh he did what
did he say he heard you made a big
splash at the meeting oh my god that was
so mean what i just said and i didn't
mean it was kevin meredith put me up to
it
okay
i'm gonna kill you
michael don't listen to them
thank you stanley you just ignored their
carpet
okay michael yes a carp is both a fish
and a term for complaining they're
mocking you with wordplay hey boss did
you find nemo i could name pixar movies
too
toy story don't you mean koi's story
and when you fell in
did you flounder
flounder is both a kind of a fish i know
what a flounder is
lower the mic for the [ __ ]
if you ever wondered whether you were
michael scott here's a quiz to help
if you ever put sunblock on a window you
might be michael scott
i normally don't enjoy making people
laugh
if you ever called the fire department
because your head was stuck in your
chair you might be
[Laughter]
[Applause]
hey hey
i don't go make burgers where you work
and then tell you how to make burgers
now i just don't think corporate's going
to go for this right now
are you wearing lady clothes
what
are you wearing lady clothes those look
like lady pants
no this is a power suit
that there's a woman's suit i do not
buy women's clothes
i would not make that mistake again i'm
gonna call roy man okay this is gonna
make all right feel better
this is too good all right you know what
pam
could you please tell daryl that this is
not a woman's suit
oh my god that's a woman's suit you're
wearing a woman's suit no i do i i wear
men's suits okay i got this out of a bin
they were these huge bins of clothes and
everybody was rifling through them like
crazy and i grabbed one
and it fit
so i don't think that this is totally
just a woman's suit
at the very least it's bisexual
who makes it
um
mysterious
and it is mysterious because the buttons
are on the wrong side
that's the mystery yeah it's got
shoulder pads do you see that line okay
would you stop it please
none of that tipped you off it's
european okay it's a european cut
michael the pants don't have any pockets
no they don't see
italians don't wear pockets it's been a
really rough couple of days
this helps a little
hey maybe you want to come over and read
my closet no i don't want to do that
because i'm twice your size anyway yeah
you look like hillary clinton
um let's just do this in 15. okay can
you stand right there for one second i
gotta send some emails i have made a
list of people that i would make out
with before i would make out with
michael scott a turtle
a fridge
anybody from the warehouse
a wood chipper
kevin
a candle
and lord voldemort anyway happy birthday
michael yeah
you'd be so lucky
good one
stanley may i talk to you for a second
stanley hudson you are fired
are you serious
i am serious we are all serious you're
fired like a heart attack you're firing
me
over three words
have you lost your mind
do you think i'm gonna let you do this
to me hmm i've watched you screw up this
office for 10 years and i'm filing a
lawsuit and i'm going to tell them about
every stupid thing you've ever done up
in this office all right okay you know
what
now you know how i feel
this was a fake firing
lesson learned good work everybody very
nice
so i'm not fired
that's it
and uh
do you have anything to say to me
oh yes i do
you are out of your damn little
pea-sized mind what is wrong with you do
you have any sense at all okay do you
have any idea how to run an office every
day you do something stupider than you
did the day before and i think there's
no possible way he can top that but what
do you do you find a way damn it to top
it you are a professional idiot hey stop
it
michael
you ran over me with your car
you posted a picture of my bear boobs on
the bulletin board with a caption that
said gross well
michael
you are the reason i drink
you are the reason i live
[Applause]
no friends only
friends only
all right mr scott this is a
copy of a particularly negative
performance review would you mind uh
reading the date on that please
march 17th and that would be a month
after your relationship became official
is that correct yes you may read the uh
highlighted portion out loud if you'd
like to
i am out of carrots
i am out of sticks
mr scott has time and again proven
himself to be an unmanageable employee
and a poor branch manager i recommend he
be removed from that position and
reassigned to sales where he belongs
mr scott after hearing that wouldn't you
say that ms levinson's judgment is
at least very seriously flawed
mr scott
several times a day michael says words
that are way beyond
my vocabulary i know where this is going
do you no okay
remember spider face no okay because the
quote was cut off your nose to spider
face spider okay
yep
how dare you all attack him like this
they'll stop it michael is your superior
no no no okay you should be bowing down
in front of him hey
are you calling me an idiot would you
ever talk to me that way you pathetic
short little man you don't have any
friends or any family or any land so how
do you search
by keyword phrase
try profits
no try michael scott
michael
boss
and
funny
oh my god
wow
email from stanley stanley
terribly nice guy sorry i didn't write
back sooner i can't go to the game
tonight because my boss michael is an
ass and making me stay late well
stanley's an ass
not one of our harder workers
what i hate about you
really suck as a ball
you're the losiest jerkiest and you're
dumber than applesauce
[Music]
we're stuck listening to you all day
stanley tried to die just to get away
when it's true
that's what i hate about you
that's what i hate about you
[Music]
[Applause]
you